vous voulez partir votre propre podcast
vous voulez à mener celui que vous avez
déjà un autre niveau
ça tombe bien on loue le studio sf ce
merveilleux studio dans lequel je suis
présentement et dans lequel également on
enregistre le sans filtre podcast parmi
tant d'autres la plupart du temps ce qui
empêche les gens de sauter dans
l'univers du podcast est en croissance
constante c'est le manque de
connaissances techniques et aussi le
manque de matériel bien qu'à cela ne
tienne dans le studio sf on loue le
studio avec tout le matériel donc tous
les micros tous les caméras si vous
voulez faire une version vidéo de votre
podcast et ça vient aussi avec notre
technicien extraordinaire nicholl
nicholl qui va vous guider dans votre
projet c'est probablement la personne au
québec qui écoutent le plus de balados
indépendant parce qu'ils derrière la
console surtout les balados qu'on
enregistre au studio sf donc il va se
faire un plaisir de vous accompagner
dans ce processus là si vous voulez plus
d'information au sujet de la location du
studio écrivez nous à sans filtre
podcast à commercial gmail.com
une production du studio sf mais mieux
sans filtre
le podcast on parle de ce qu'on veut que
nos invités date si tu cherches quentin
avec moi doom plan doom le podcast
semaine et présenté par vegan les
peuplades tombe de encore une fois
deuxième livre de recettes 80 recette
simple facile avec tout des ingrédients
faciles à portée de main on a des pains
dorés on a du bacon de tofu on a des
sautes et on a de tout pour tout le
monde
des burgers pour toute la famille donc
si vous pensez suite à plusieurs
discussions qu'ont eues sur le podcast
ou sur ta juste votre propre éducation
personnel réduire votre consommation de
produits d'origine animale chose que
vous devriez faire ne serait ce que pour
l'environnement
ben
vous pouvez le faire facilement avec
beghal mais papa tombe deux donc le lien
va être dans la déception pour vous
procurer notre livre en ligne
elle vous garantit vous serez pas déçus
comme cela s'était mal on a reçu du
temple un retour pour la troisième fois
sur le podcast
je suis toujours flatté gasté par pardus
temple dans le podcast cgt comme figé
parce que ces gueux le rayon tellement
de positivisme de 2,2 vouloir des tangos
qui discipline de fer tingaud qui qui
est drôle qui est gentil si ce sera
quelqu'un que je trouve inspirant
ouais c'est ça c'est là l'inspiration
que que jay transmet dans sa propre
personne jeter comme pas mal podcast
jeter a remise en question personnelle
puis je me dis comment je peux être
folichon mais comment je peux être aussi
aux sommes que des doutes non mais c'est
vrai ça va vraiment craquer les
conversations avec lui ça me fait du
bien ça m'a donné le goût de me botter
le cul de remettre en question certaines
afin de récupérer certaines affaires qui
c'est toujours un plaisir de parler il y
tellement faim c'est vraiment loin puis
là on a décidé avec jay c'était le
premier podcast compter paix dans le
studio depuis la réouverture c'était pas
le premier qui est sorti mais c'est le
premier qu'on comptait paix dans le
studio puis on les défende deux portes
fait que la première partie vous la
regardez présentement sur la chaîne sans
filtre fait que si vous venez en ce
moment du la chaîne de jay salut tout le
monde on est le sans-fil podcast mais
fait qu'on a fait la première partie sur
le sans filtre vous allez voir à la fin
de la conversation on est encore
extrêmement intéressé par la
concentration c'était fou mais on a
changé de chaîne donc on est allé sur la
chaîne de jeu du temps discute donc
dirigez vous vers le pour voir la suite
de la discussion une autre heure qui est
tout aussi passionnante
''j'ai quincaille parle il parle à
andrée qui réfléchit à voix haute que tu
le suis vraiment facilement dans son
raisonnement
comme toi moi aussi j'étais un petit peu
un remise en question pendant le podcast
on en a reparlé en sortant le sait comme
je peux parler beaucoup parce que je
réfléchissais non mais j'ai été jeté
dans ma tête parce que telle idée
tellement raison sous peine à faire
piéger legouge d'appliquer ce que lui
applique l'été dans sa vie puis s'éteint
gauche tamaki expliquer les objectifs
mais des gros objectifs
ghachi john juin exactement exactement
fait qu'on espère que ça va vous motiver
autant que ça nous a craqué nous autres
fait qu'écouter participer aux
conversations écrit un commentaire à
l'écouté la deuxième peut être surtout
du temps discute puis pis non sinon ce
sans plus attendre bonne bon podcast
bonne écoute
[Musique]
yes on est de retour premier podcast
enregistré dans le studio et c'est
résiliation bravo les garçons
préparation je suis tellement contente
tellement content de faire quelque chose
qui qui se rapproche de ma job matin
j'étais vraiment heureux donc j'avais
l'impression télé en plus on est début
juin ma petite soeur au matin on prenait
un café puis comme h tellement excitée
enjeux risquant la fin de l'école moi
dans ma tête
non moi matin c'est la rentrée
maintenant à dakhla
ça fait ça fait du bien on a
l'impression de d'avoir été sur pause
longtemps pour plus longtemps que la
réalité est ce qu'il y aura plus c'est
que je pense que c'est je peux moi j'ai
réalisé que je sors quand on doit
repartir enfin si j'aurais dû plus
relaxe et j'ai réalisé que j'étais pas
bon du tout pour relaxer 11 alexis je
culpabilisais tout le pain rien faire
fait que je me suis mis à travailler
dans le champ chez mes parents parce que
monet jeter comme mandje dort mal le
jour je pas bien le ministre kambere je
travaille 10 heures dans ce changement
entraîne deux heures je mange le
cauchemar il dormait bien parce qu'elles
soient mieux ça m'amène parce que rien
faire c'était puissant possible
c'est ce que oui c'est bizarre même ses
besoins la dernière fois que j'ai été
aussi inactif
c'était peut-être trop les partager avec
moi puis je pense que c'était pire le
d'être inactif avec les nouvelles
mondiales
oui dans la situation du monde
actuellement de me sentir complètement
impuissant que la seule puissance que
j'avais c'est justement d'être isolé
chez nous mais de recevoir l'influent
nouvelle constante comme à l
il ya plein de bons petits maurer la
mare des paniers d'un ch et celle des
puits jusqu'à la semaine dernière où est
ce que là c'est apparemment une guerre
civile aux aux états unis qu'on est
comme chez nous à faire ok loges c'est
il ya une manifestation liam et moi mais
je me dis balade est ce qu'on jette par
la fenêtre toutes les précautions qu'on
a pris pendant deux mois restants dans
ses caisses que sur quel pied danser
puis en même temps des copains puissants
par rapport à ça fait que je préfère
quasiment être coupé complètement des
nouvelles du monde battu que de vivre
dans comme une espèce de puissance
constante le la grand-mère à des
blocages on a mis des buts à lille a
salué pas longtemps une côté quai parce
qu'elle a les outils de 99 accueil est
comme un gamin tout vécu la deuxième
guerre mondiale quand elle avait comme
20 ans et l'autre vit la copie de 19,6
sa grand-mère à le dire je t'aime un peu
la guerre au moins y avait pas y avait
il n'y avait pas arrêter le baseball
[Rires]
mais
au moins le bva c'est drôle mais mais
pour vrai s'ils avaient encore chez moi
j'étais un fan de hockey de basket de
football s'ils avaient encore ces choses
le sahara était plus facile d'avoir au
moins une trame narrative à suivre la
seule chose que j'avais à suivre si t'es
ok aujourd'hui de netflix a décidé de
sortir cette série locke a guère que
tout le monde parle de ce crime
c'est la seule chose qui apparaît
absolument c'est assez vraiment c'est
fox c'est vraiment fucked mais ammann et
maintient cette semaine ça a été une
super semaine où les restes comme et
qu'est ce qui se passe est il vraiment
un métier un point c'est comme acquis
atteint le monde sait pas ce qu'on me
pose pas ce point fort est ici c'est
notre vie à berne en ôter sa première
fois de ma vie que pauvre et j'ai fait
et il le faut qu'on se réveille à manier
comme faux pauvres elle pose pour une
vraie faire c'est un passé c'est
parodique qui sait ben trop intense le
tpiy ça prend forme je suis pas
quelqu'un qui chaque bébé d'invités je
suis pas quelqu'un qui se révoltent
beaucoup pile avec toute l'histoire de
georges flouret dans le contexte le j'ai
fait est là le pauvre et le wake 2 fois
coptes tout le monde wake de phoque a
fait apport fokine big rhein genre
officieux lee pose des questions j t
elle sa part fondre la vie jeter comme
asti j'ai
je veux me révolte et moi aussi je
comprends qu'ils gueulent tabarnak
personnes écoutées facom année c'est
comme l'impuissance a pas de l'urti ce
qui se passe qu'est non j'étais comme
vraiment un point
j'allais pas bien mon moi fait que je
pouvais pas imaginer maintenant et les
gens qui kiffent qui vivent le racisme
dite quotidiennement depuis début leur
vip et heureusement hier j'anime un live
pour le requin ce qui est une dose de
bonheur men je m'en allais l'appui
j'étais nerveux parce que je suis pas
longtemps j'avais rien fait comme par
rapport à ma job un peu bien là ça va
peut-être baguette c'est pas trop les
gens des attentes tu veux pas fauqué
rien et ça m'a fait tellement bien parce
qu'on dirait que j'ai fait aux pieds nus
du monde empathique et du monde
solidaire voire une petite soeur de 8
ans faire le défi têtes rasées pour sa
grande soeur de 11 ans qui combattit le
cancer et 5 1 they came et à 8 ans elle
la petite et inquiètent déjà au brooke
et ça fait deux ans qu'elle veut se
faire raser les cheveux parce que comme
yo ma soeur a été quelque chose
d'intense je veux être solide à je vais
être empathique à sa situation plus
jeter comme hockey et vélo on est
correct il ya de l'espoir encore dit ça
m'a vraiment ça a été avant l'heure en
partant je suis fils et popi goethe
arriver là ça me fait tellement bien
pire ok il faut juste entendre les bonne
voie aussi été ouais c'est ça la force
et ce qui est difficile d'en tirer on le
sait on le sait en s'exposant au public
les commentaires que tu reviens que tu
retiens même si l'école esmod du positif
tu retiens lille a en fait qu'ils
imaginent qu'un cataclysme online
comment s'étoffe de t'accrocher au
positif chez moi ce qui m'a vraiment qui
me donnait envie de littéralement mettre
des bombes
c'est dans une situation comme comme ce
soit la coved où la situation récemment
c'est un aux états puis même ici à
montréal cherche toujours dans une
société qui se veut civile cherche
toujours le support des autorités puis
ce qui me donne vraiment moi ce qui me
perturbe le plus c'est le président des
états unis
moi c'est ça qui me donne le plus envie
qu'il sait des bombes partout parce que
c'est ça pourrait pas être la pire
personne pour gérer cette situation le
ca pourrait pas être la pire personne
n'en parlait juste avant leur entrée
c'est si c'est barack obama qui quitte à
la tête des états unis en ce moment on
n'a pas cette situation là oui il ya des
entrées de jouer si jo le flou une mort
il ya quand même une baisse mais c'est
tellement réglé dans la compassion plus
rapidement là c'est la pire personne
attend depuis j'ai c'est un sujet qui
polarise en parler de politique hostile
mais le mois moi je suis rendu dans un
état où est ce que je me dit écoute je
me colle c'est de choquer des gens je
trouve que c'est inacceptable dans une
société en 2000 - je trouve que c'est le
pire dirigeants qui pourrait qu'ils
pourraient avoir à avoir séparé de la
motte et puis du racisme du profilage
racial du 10 où il avait aussi sauf que
je pense qu'ils les différents ça serait
ce que tu mets de l'huile sur le feu
après ou tapez tapez à être les tensions
je pense que c'était il y avait quelque
chose de ce budget qui circule est pas
mal c'était comme une comparaison du
tweed de tram si c'était un tweet par
rapport aux prothèses qui avait eu des
personnes blanches quitté juste a dit
confirmant qu'il voulait ouvrir son
coffre option huit années puis le lait
protestent en ce moment à pitre il
toutes les perturbations que cela
implique c'était comme un tweet qui
parlait des personnes blanches pizzetti
si faut être compréhensif très bonne
personne mais sont justes année puis
l'eau c'était vraiment lisbonne s'était
fixé comme il ya vraiment aucune
empathie compassion envers ce que ces
gens là
yves qui dit neige 6 depuis des siècles
mais s'il faut aussi parce que je
parlais avec mais paraît pas longtemps
si de mon père parle beaucoup de trous
mais tombe bien
manille est un joker et on était en voie
effet tant j'étais un peu quand même été
surpris comme cindy one puis et puis m'a
juste dit on mais faut pas arrêter de se
choquer moi j'étais comme auch ita
réseau met un fork in raison faut pas
arrêter d'être choqués de ce guerrier
faut pas jeter rendu en poche de gamme
mais à quoi est il comme vous vous
attendiez à quoi dégager mais dimanche
c'est comme à ce point de raisons pour
pas est en révolte contre lui tu es
était à à quelle vitesse puisque ça leur
ep je comprends même pas pourquoi ça le
passé à quelle vitesse est ce que le
guarbecque de possibles à quelle vitesse
est ce qu'elle est ce que le monde de
passer à autre chose
voyons donc avez-vous checker le
documentaire lui non non moi je tenais
après j'ai au début du confinement
comme vingt deux mondes j'écoutais tiger
king puis ça me faisait pas sentir bien
gt gt gamache peux pas faut vraiment que
je fasse attention à ce que je consomme
comme séries télé comme films comme
podcast pour vraiment me nourrir de la
bonne affaire dans ce contexte
oui et de lutter tiger king ne faisait
vraiment pas le seul thème faisais quand
j'étais pas bien et j'ai écouté et
laurie puis je suis vraiment zéro en
politique je connais vraiment pas ce
sujet pour suivi ça de près puis fac tu
finis par jeu savoir un peu
inconsciemment l'opinion des gens qui
tentent au web et puis évidemment que
menait 40-15 tenir le week en titre a
jeté comme meilleur score qu'il faut que
ce soit les objectifs puis y'a pas tu ne
sois pas un humoriste et américains qui
est dit dans ces spéciales comme les les
humains les américains pouvaient pas
passer du premier black president alors
comme un femme c'était comme trop
d'émotion c'était comme si quelqu'un
vient de sauter en parachute depuis des
cas terry fait ok bon ça va du bungee
mon billet et je trouve que dans le
documentaire évidemment documentaire de
base sa salle a une opinion neutre à un
ongle veut pas meilleur endroit pour moi
je trouve que ça et redonne un peu ses
lettres de noblesse à el-arish tout ça
j'ai eu de la peine
en écoutant ça j'ai eu de la vraie peine
j'ai pleuré de faire je peux pas croire
qu'elle a perdu c'est vraiment vraiment
une défaite qui fait mal et puis les
véhicules complètement retard déjà je
savais me souviens la soirée électorale
ou trump est rentré j'avais temps chaud
puis j'étais rentré chez nous que
j'avais vu si je mets que je me dis que
ça 3 heures du matin le temps de savoir
que je croyais pas le bon réflexe
l'armée matin j'avais j'avais des trucs
comme ça veut dire qu un celi après
george était comment tout avec un seul
litre ont pu rentrer et et puis le gîte
chez lui puis chez carmen c'est une
femme qui est impliqué since the one
dans les communautés ethniques étaient
présentes à connais les noms
hélas le tic puis à stx et pas glam de
la politique là mon dieu que ces
problèmes-là des soupers spaghetti bien
ouais dont le pied le puits a connaît
son affaire puis à mennecy roues un
tabac à nantes puis j'ai eu c'est vrai
j'ai vraiment trouvé ça bon j'ai
vraiment aimé ce puits alors c'est
vraiment sympa je pense que tu ne t'y
mets le doigt dessus l'artiste est
vraiment ça aurait été probablement un
homme blanc à la place de l'airé clinton
puis on en serait probablement pas le
tuer je pense que c'était juste le show
était trop trop grand - mais ce qui me
fascine en plus c'est que en quelques
pas là dedans on est comme tout gamin on
est comme à l'intimidation dans les
écoles c'est non tolérance zéro je
regardais je m'attendais un pack
furieuse l'intimidation puis c'est
accepté il ya vingt personnes qui
arrêtent rien mais si c'est accepté mais
se passer la personne qui sait seule
affaire c'est que c'est la plus haute
instance c'est comme il ya pas
d'intimidation à l'école mais quand là
quand le directeur intimident les
professeurs mettons et c'est la plus
haute instance du fait que c'est qui qui
qui qui qui tape ses doigts du directeur
fin qui fait qu'on sait c'est la merde
c'est la merde
hilary elle est vraiment été brenda si
comme malades à être comme jean menteur
statique et l'autre on le suit genre qui
était mettons ce pas si c'était
quantifiable se fait le devoir ou cook a
menti c'est que c'est tellement j'ai dit
open qui s'est quasiment l'autre le 6
octobre - il s'en cache pas ses
bénéfices l'intimidation juste dans le
baseball ses piges
j'ai entendu il a 8 ans on reparlait à
prêter de l'ammoniaque qui sont non
verbale qui elle parlait la meilleure
qui se poserait en plus comme derrière
elle qui sont polis tu vous ferez le
faire-part physiquement vraiment des
vieilles techniques de cour d'école
c'est fou mais je vous conseille le
documentaire sekkat épisode sûr que je
le sens c'est vraiment vraiment bon
c'est bien fait pisser comme
jean-jacques trouve vraiment résiliente
d'être encore là aujourd'hui d'études
encore s'impliquer et steam je n'ai
jamais vécu je pense le dixième de ce
qu'a vécu j'en ai pour mme ben jawad
brigade il patiente le 4 mai
j'écoutais ce que j'écoutais le
ces peluches ornent le sait
by comme celui des hauts près au projet
en voyant mes chats obama s'est aussi
j'étais gamin il faut un peu que je me
dis que c'est pas mal la chose la plus
grand public l'été un documentaire d'une
heure et quart sur netflix de meshal
obama est pas rendu mais archi on n'est
pas loin
puis c'est plus sur le vraiment si
charles and sweet
mais c'est aussi j'ai fait comme est
émouvant c'est nice de voir quel point
un simplet coup si elle aussi le tice
calvi qui fument en commun ils et les
analystes politiques opposés aux states
ils sont vraiment off avec les femmes
vraiment heures fleuty le fait qu'elle
ait fait un fils baume par son mari les
gens fêtent comme nom anonops aymen sa
guise
c'est leur affaire est vraiment solide
puis puis c'est cela était à paarl la
première fois qu'ils allaient rencontrer
barack obama suscite tellement seuil est
vraiment vraiment spécialisé puis
jusqu'à il ya les deux ont été rudes et
elle était sa tutrice
moi j'avais besoin non plus de sa
tutrice pour un cours de chypre coin
puis avec un premier rendez vous qu'on
se donne c'est il m'appelle et sa voix
tout le monde autour étaient calmes à tf
vous allez finir ensemble super comme
c'est juste que vous voulez gens les
deux blacks deux sortants semblent aller
chier tu t'es comme cai est arrivé dans
pièce j'ai fait comme moi si et si et si
le fun de voir commenter et c'est
l'implication sociale d'une personne
prête toi pravo vraiment une influence
sur ton implication sociale tchèque lui
le fait qu'ils prennent position
les frais le le fait qu'ils s'impliquent
dans la communauté le fait qu elle dit
elle même et que mieux fallu que moi
cette époque ma game cinq hommes avaient
si je veux être avec ce que le faux que
faut que je m'implique il faut que je
fasse ma part faut que vous que choisir
ma cause il faut que je fasse tellement
avoir meilleur ami comme joystick
jusqu'à sa monnaie c'est comme ab tu
peux pas être indifférents aux nouveaux
arrivants syrie ne peut pas être
indifférent à l'immigration ne peut pas
être été fait comme année c'est quand
même un nom crise est tombé à rome puis
il passe ses dimanches matin par des
sols d'église a donné des informations
des nouveaux abonnés pour chat n'est pas
là alors qu'il pourrait être dans un
cabinet à fort de 500 à 1000 par année
et c'est pas ce qui venant 6e puis son
implication fait comme aux riches et de
faux que moi je me botte le cul fille
fac et j'ai trouvé ça va comme fait du
bien de voir qu'ils ont annoncé ces ya
du beau monde
et oui ces exemples aussi si michelle
obama c'est ce que son mari de président
des états unis métier l'exemple pas
besoin d'être élu pour faire une
différence aussi dans le monde des ti pu
avoir un impact positif je m'enferme
sont améliorées ou comme elle
pis si elles sont ou de d'appréciation
aux états unis et de chat parce que tu
sais juste et des gens qu'il sent que
c'est juste des fois king bonne personne
mais ce qui coule en fait ce que je
faisais un manet première femme première
dans la première ce lundi
et c'est comme à part la dernière
journée qui ont quitté la maison blanche
estime bien comme il y avait quelque
chose de huit ans qu'on se fait chic et
non stop tout le temps le caecum en même
temps ce laisse la maison trompe t elle
était comme je veux pas pleurer
incertain pourquoi je pleure parce que
faut pas que les gens aient cette
information le sait je veux pas que les
gens pensent quelque chose puis parce
que c'est vraiment fascinant tpiy est ce
que je trouve cool c'est que quand même
évidemment le cas fait attention à son
image tout mais quand même tu l'écoutent
parité comme un nom à qui on est
et quand même authentique dans cette
espèce de position impossible d'imaginer
comment faudrait-il être authentique
quand justement tu es un petit mot à
côté une maladresse
et en plus fait juste sous la tente
juste que tu trébucher me afane
évidemment pas ses mots ce que tu dis tu
prépares plus speed perd un peu de
nature elle-même c'est des gens
regardent juste mettons tous les points
de presse de le goal t ils font leur
milieu il ya c'est de faire une bonne
job subtil les journalistes font leur
travail aussi puis ils sont importants
mais si tu vois qu'il ya un 1 2 leur but
c'est de coincer leurs questions de ccc
de trouver la faille dans ton affaire
avec aux états unis mène justement obama
le cas c'est speed jamais ton blanche
c'est comme qui qui qui qui brûlait at
qu alcoa maladroite et 10 et 8 ans
évidemment il faut il ya l'histoire de
quelqu'un que croisé philippe trillaud
genre la semaine après la fin de son
deuxième mandat à l'aéroport de montréal
avec un sac à dos voyageurs puis il
faisait déjà s'en aller un voyage de sac
à dos le un bac bac le genre fois que le
mot nigérien maintenant il ya un compte
twitter le flop new york puis comme là
son dernier tweet c'est comme la soirée
ou skis ou est-ce qui est parti pigeât
c'est après ça c'est moi je la garde
complète
didot tingle salle après salle at elle
vraiment off mais j'aime beaucoup et
j'ai qu'est ce que tu disais par rapport
aux gens qui t'entourent way qu'est-ce
qu'est ce que tu as envie de faire
qu'est ce que tu as envie de faire pour
amener du positif d'un geste sûr que tu
as pensé si tu as tellement voudrait
tellement une grande tribune te sentir
infinie de ressources jeudi citant un
projet possiblement qui peut qui peut
voir le jour le petit fake
qu'est ce que tu as envie de voir
qu'est-ce qui trône en tête mais la
presse et que c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'ai pris des vacances un petit
j'ai fait le centre bell puis
félicitations la vidéo que ça m'a donné
des frissons
g
j'ai la réécoute de temps à autres
bijoux j'ai encore le motton le thé à
chaque fois que j'en parle avec mon
entourage parce que c'était vraiment un
truc collectif je faisais segment
famille mes amis
c'était tout des amis qui travaillait
sur chaud ça a été spécial pour tout le
monde c'est moi qui étais de vin mais
c'était vraiment un afad
j'ai vraiment eu l'impression que ben
c'est tout nous autres qui fait en sorte
que ceci cesse à 100 dans cette vidéo le
maire cette vidéo qui suit la journée
c'est vraiment comme ses toiles c'est
pour te connais mieux que la guest la
population générale comme c'est vraiment
toi le titre une heure au dîner arrête
son lift on livre des on regarde la
routine même si tu es vraiment comme un
gamin
l'ancien athlète que tu es le tir de
gamme à qui on met une routine puis on
la change pas peu importe c'est quoi la
grosseur de la game absolument puis qui
arrive après c'est ce que c'était est-ce
que c'était aussi incroyable que cela
leur sueur c'est ce que je trouve
oui pour le oui même plus ce qui est
spécial en fait ce que je trouve ça
vraiment cool comment je sais pas si
vous autres c'est sûr et moins ce que
dame dans ma carrière pour l'instant
puis je dirais même pas simplement dans
ma vie les choses arrivent au bon moment
je me trouve chanceux pour ce type je
trouve que j'ai fait le centre bell au
bol j'aime bien gallas pour il était
passé ça a été une vraiment bonne
préparation pour le centre bell parce
que c'était stressant c'était gros
c'était important pour moi de one shot
et one shot qui fait en sorte qu'on
dirait que pour le centre belge et une
grosse préparation très athlétique
préparation mentale très très grande
donc la semaine à vin chaud j'ai
pratiquement vu personne
j'ai vu ma famille j'ai vu dave et c'est
tout au nouvel ange pas sorti jeter à
maison et dave puis son frère puis
ont-ils je voulais et je voulais comme
pote dépenser d'énergie à faire du small
talk avec n'importe qui ou si tout ce
qui m'habitait tous qui habitait mon
esprit c'était le centre bell la semaine
avant la grosse exact jeter comme à
soient concentrées là tu puisses
caracter et les deux soupers à 20 donc
le 1er janvier le 2 janvier j'ai subi
chez mes parents c'est là que j'habitais
puis il ça a été des super on a juste
parlé de tubes avec mes parents le
premier set avec mes parents ma petite
soeur son copain puis ma petite soeur
même à me dit tu réaliste us qui est en
train de nous faire vivre ses pieds
tamani motif de sopi et comme en plus tu
changes poté départ et et pie x qui
avait quelque chose de même moi je te
comme venant de ma petite soeur me temps
j'ai trouvé ça vraiment fort parce que
sarah
à pas pour rien dire puis c'est comme ma
première femme c'est ma petite soeur
cela prend personne que j'ai fait très
sa propre personne que je veux toujours
l'affairé s'est fait qu'il y avait
quelque chose et puis mes parents on en
a je sentais que eux aussi avaient
besoin d'en parler beaucoup autant que
moi on a beaucoup échangé là dessus puis
la veille du show je savais j'avais déjà
préparé il y avait des trucs été un peu
comme toi tous des tagueurs king pour
moi dans le confinement ça faisait plus
je me nourrissais pas de la bonne
affaire
ben la veille du centre bell je savais
ce que j'allais écouter
j'écoutais la fin du documentaire de
lady gaga fast food ou que je sais pas
si vous avez écouté mais tlc le
documentaire qui la suit jusqu'au à son
show de la mi temps 11 rebonds puis
piqué fokine discipline il était
vraiment vraiment à son affaire puis
très très très travaillante très
exigeante envers elle même et donc avoir
les autres puis à l'arrivée la journée
du super bowl qui sont gérés comme
consulter des bobines même auteur de
bonne humeur et commentent j'ai vu des
images de moi répète j'ai l'air de
vouloir tuer tout le monde même les
comme c'est tellement bête mais c'est
tellement le fun ce qui s'apprête à ce
passé j'ai pas le droit de ne pas ma
muse moi et moi cette phrase ne me
restait d'entacher comme ces gros 6 très
sain mais je n'ai pas le droit de ne pas
m'amuser j'ai pas le droit
il faut que je sois plaisant avec tout
le monde cette journée là c'est super
spéciale puis je veux regarder un bon
souvenir si j'écoutais une entrevue de
kobe bryant c'est tellement bon compte
mais c'est vrai aussi que ce soit en
reste est sorti et kobe est décédé un
mois près pige pas je prends un grand
fan de basket mais ce qui représentait
plus je connaissais son éthique de
travail puis connaissait sa discipline
pile celle entrevue lui c'est ce qu'ils
disent elles dans l'entrevue sait il
comment les caches entrer dans une bille
et cher pour combien temps j'allais être
là dedans enfin j je voulais pas l'âge
où je prenais pas de vacances
la journée où ça allait se terminer je
n'ai pas produit
j'aurais pu en faire plus mais qui était
comme il travaille tout le temps il
n'arrêtait jamais
piet fait que j'écoutais ça j'étais
j'écoutais des trucs précis le tai chi
mon kiki m'alimenter de la bonne affaire
de manière positive de manière comme
humble humaine puissante vrai enjeu
c'est paul puis mène je me suis réveillé
ce matin là et je souhaite à déjeuner je
t'ai que mes parents puis c'est lorsque
mon lift mêmes cherchent à 10 ans gagne
était à la route le temps des fêtes
crise on se loue un groove et us noir
comme livre d'être fond on le fait et on
le vit puis mon livre est pas arrivé
depuis très longtemps 10h10 et les
derniers du monde en 10 minutes que mes
parents étaient comme quoi de parler de
rien c'est juste qu'on attendait j'étais
un peu quand je les fêtards en classe et
ça a été les tarifs jusqu'au bleu domine
au delà je crois qu'il faut que la
préparation était pas fait faillite et
puis c'est si tu veux j'ai retiré la
vidéo
pendant ce temps nouvelle zélande j'ai
démontré au go avec qui je voyage et que
j'ai rencontré là bas au pied et les
deux ont été d'un café à christchurch
pour amman puis il était comme je
n'avais pas beaucoup parler tant que ce
type à ce qu on avait tellement part à
20 puis apprécier vraiment des plugins
le lendemain ce sont des choses à fureur
trois quatre jours après je m'en allais
dans la gaspésie bien merci je parte en
voyage fac
c'était comme j'y porte croisé le monde
qui est elle est avec moi soit le temps
que sub ce qu'évidemment on a par leur
permet pas en long et en large et et
puis quand j'ai réécouté vidéo avec lui
en nouvelle-zélande il fait même moi je
pense qu'il faut que tu leur écoute
souvent comme faut qu'ils soient fiers
de toi c'est pratique c'est passé c'est
vraiment spécial
ça a été une soirée super vraiment
vraiment le pied tout s'est bien passé
d'extraordinaire téléphone nécessaires
auront été à la hauteur
maintenant je veux pas sa journée au
centre bell on
fait l'été je paye pour un style jusqu'à
nos managers m'entraîner et yéyé lieu
d'un jim auxquelles on a accès on avait
le jim de l'adversaire du canadien fait
que montrer n'est venu on s'est
entraînés après ça on a mangé après ce
j'ai poussé mon stage avec les
techniciens c'est puis je trouvais ça
cool de force est jetée comme ngc ici on
vit même temps c'est la gamme wave et le
plus c'est que j'ai entendu quelques
fêtes comme wendy et d'enfants fret à la
fois mais lorsque je me suis un peu
comme en bref ils m'ont dit à 1h30
pousse le stage puis moi maintenant je
disposais partir à une heure et demie
chaque homme mais je petit poucet ce
texte aux sitcoms que c'est mon style
justin jeudi par ce biais à le pousser
dans ce test ce sera pas l'anglais on a
à moitié de l'aréna poussé l'espagne
quittons le baril vers 1h45 comme
parfait puis jeté comme une des
premières fois que tu te fais 10 du
moins puisque moi à l'école de l'humour
cadets choquant je conçois pas des
choses beaucoup dit il faut que tu
respectes et m6
si nicole épaules en ce moment même le
micro ils marchent pas obligés aucune
idée comment qui marche du fait que
c'est des histoires de tête et de dégoût
d'artistes qui fait chier le texte le
tec coupe le son avant on parle de sa
réussite et enfin que moi j'ai beaucoup
garder ça en tête puis moins précis cgt
regrettant tout qui vient du support
tchèque est une enfant de deux sportifs
des clips de faire un monde c'est tout
le monde participe et un à ce que je
puisse embarquer sur ce n est qu un bon
shoot côté des juke
mais comme seul c'est vrai que c'est
impossible que je le fasse et fin qui
est fait que j'ai poussé mon style je
trouvais ça cool seppi
après ce bain on ne voulait aller faire
une sieste à l'hôtel puis on était mômes
sharon est sorti la sieste tout dormi
non toi non 20 trop excités et la tester
le système à la le système malade
charles pellerin était tellement bon le
titre embarquée sur cinq pieds tu es
comme cheese hurle t y était vraiment
vraiment vraiment bon le type j'ai parlé
que ses parents combien jours après et
puis c'est pour c'est pour sa famille
aussi c'était quelque chose
fakir et tirer dix mille personnes y
avait du monde jusqu'en haut
tiens on a remis un super beau chèque à
le requin fakty oui c'est un trip sa
propre eau ne pas être un trip d'ego
c'est impossible mais je trouve que puis
mon père était comme sur ce coup là que
ton show s'appelle bien faire se termine
en faisant le défi têtes rasées pour le
requin comme tout se prend tellement son
sens et quant aux deux tontons prochain
prochain titre de chou est mieux d'être
bon mais c'était comme artiste est
vraiment vraiment le fun puisque et
espèce et que tout le long du spectacle
moi chaque jokes de la dent faujas
contexte est comme vraiment spécial
d'être broggi pleure sur la pause une
farine vélos fleuris super cool pis
après sa belle
et c'est mon équipe avait fait ils sont
malades sion il y avait une coupe de
photographe sur place puis ils ont
choisi deux photos que pendant ce
spectacle
charles de bain une médium 13 du show
est allé à une place de photos faire
imprimer les biens que je débarque et de
seine qui avait une photo du show
encadrer toutes mes amis ma famille
avait signé en arrière que jeter comme
jetant page des frissons le tibet via
les ja vichy rose et tout le monde a
tripé ti et karim ouellet préfet les dj
set safina main que chanter pendant que
je me faisais raser les cheveux marcus
qui rosissent fric médecin l'équipe ma
femme c'était fou après se rencontrer la
gagne 2 le caire rencontrer les
gentilles avait il y avait des gens que
je rencontrais pour les photos la
pression on avait regardé un after party
au centre bell c'était mon ami mélodies
qui rendu ma styliste rodez qui est
aussi dj dj son assiette charade qui
mixait cherchait quelqu'un pour votre
mariage
oui c'est ça puis
et je suis rentré naïvement je rentre à
l'after paris puis on avoir des
chandelles était juste pour les amis de
la famille étaient petits je te lance en
belgique mais crocs puis jetée comme le
même feeling j'avais un feeling il n'ya
pas d'adultes qui nous surveillent c'est
nous autres
naïvement j'arrivais à l'after poli je
sais pas pourquoi je t'ai comme c'est en
rentrant que je réagisse comme je
connais tout le monde ici c'est quand
même mieux que ma femme était dans ma
tête j'allais avoir des inconnus sais
pas pourquoi c'est ça je comprends
j'avais la tête qui juste me cacher on a
dansé jusqu'à 2 3 heures du matin puis
remaniée ont fermé le bateau kiwi c'est
fermé puis était pas trop acheter les
objets man je veux vraiment pas faire
chier je sais pas ce qui s'est passé
mais je peux te vends une bière puis
comme pourquoi fermer le bassiste au
camp fêtes où il vient juste derrière on
on veut juste pas que les gens doivent
prendre une bière on va t'expliquer je
conviens chu puissants comme c'est que
un peu débordements tièdement qui ont
vomi à se jeter comme un peu content que
mon acheteur s'arrête c'est cool parties
s'écoutent pluie puis melo a été
tellement tu as le fini son mix la
donnant une camille vial avait prévu
coustet la tonne jérémy a tout vu tout
entendu c'était tellement hausse comme
c'était vraiment vraiment une belle
veillée puis fac tout ça pour dire
qu'ils étaient pour moi c'est ça sa
clause un chapitre c'est le fait couper
les cheveux on avait par un plus si
c'était comme ça représentait quelque
chose pour moi aussi puis après ça
l'idée de partir tout seul dans une
vanne en nouvelle-zélande pour penser à
tout ce absorber tout sûr puisque j'ai
appris des dents et puis justement je
suis encore en réflexion savoir what's
next
qu'est ce que je veux faire qu'est ce
qui est important pour moi qu'est ce que
je veux je suis rendu avec un genre de
ces 6es les gens soient rebondir assez
quand une tribune faut que tu l'utilisés
sopi je t'ai d'accord avec ça mais je le
suis de plus en plus longtemps
comme annoncé ce g et qu'est ce que tu
vois c'est en écoutant jean-michel obama
parlait que des jeunes qui comme qu'est
ce que watson pour thank you qu'est ce
qui est important
pour toi haute et puis c'est quand même
un oui qu'est ce qui est important pour
moi pis de véhicules et c'est d'essayer
du monde
enfin ça veut pas dire que je peux pour
faire des jokes de pertes le disent pas
ce que je dis mais de faire du moins
attitude en podcast satellite qu'est ce
que j'ai envie de faire
faction encore en réflexion mais je les
idées se clarifie puis aussi des fois si
je sais pas vous mais cette fois c'est
dur au cerveau des idées quant aux
stands quand tu fais rien puis c'est
comme ça tout devient un terrifiant et
il s'est quand même pas qu'est ce qui
est possible ou si c'est ça je ne sais
pas qu'est ce qui serait beau être
possible quand ces caisses qui est
possible de planifier dans un futur
rapproché c'est vraiment un certain mais
je pense que le jeu parle vraiment
beaucoup depuis début mai je pense que
quelque chose qui que j'aimerais
possiblement participé à ramener au
québec c'est l entrevue la culture de
l'entrevue s'est on en n'est plus
vraiment d'entrevue que tout le monde
fait faut que tu écoutes cette émission
lundi quand christiane charette faisait
d'une entrevue c'est quand même faut
opter coûte cette charrette et puis on a
eu plein d'autres l'avant après mais
l'autriche comme si j'écoutais départ
casey jones trimble la politique et à
toronto puis jeté comme un qui a un nom
c'est la culture de l'entrevue c'est là
que je pense que c'est dans cette
direction que je vais aller puis j'ai
beaucoup appris c'est ici un territoire
ccfa qui fait que dans cette direction
comme j'ai plein d'autres idées à voir
mais il y a
je suis pas mal je reprenne enfin je
veux je plaide la fois ci ce qui fascine
emphatique et ça prend un faut que je
prenne une vraie pause puis vient un
moment de brouillard le team ngs en
norvège et en nouvelle zélande et ce
fait est que tu fais de sujets pas
l'espèce fait deux semaines à peine que
juin tout en valant vente
jeanine que je l'avait appelé vingt puis
y est on
je rentre à
j'oublie mon avis le cheminement bref je
rends dans une grande ville dans le sud
de l'île du nord
et ça fait j'ai pas le une semaine que
je suis dans bruce le mouton et le genre
entre danville wellington je rende en
ville puis ça vaut mais ça vaut correct
on retire je me pose un peu des
questions à savoir comment ça se fait
que je serai pas plus sa présence je me
sens ici comme tout le monde a été mon
voyage avant que je parte ça me
stressait parce qu'on dirait que je
savais que j'allais patrie paix autant
que d'autres le disais ouais parce que
j'aime beaucoup ma vie si j'ai ma job
j'aime faire des podcasts j'ai mes amis
j'ai ma famille j'aime les restos
logement j'aime tout ce que je suis fais
tu y vas que je fuis rien quand je pars
en voyage c'est vraiment juste pour me
confronter et le jarret ta lumière rouge
qui est dans une pente et je te
contentes jeanine et emmanuel ses piges
comores faut que j'arrête d'une pente
menthe et c'est une grosse vanne quand
même et là ça tombe vers je lâche la
clutch donne du gaz pipeau petit comme
je conduis bien manuel de la clotte
spaety ma culotte lors je vous dis pas
et là je commence à reculer le jeu mais
librex kamio qu'est-ce qui se passe
le geste gérer ces gens recul le ch
comme foc foc foc foc foc cm cic le guet
je voyage laurent qui est le frère à
guillaume girard mon amertume que j'ai
croisé là par hasard qu'ils étaient là
par hasard c'est le nom c'est guillaume
question mon frère arrive le lendemain
si jamais on s'était vu une fois tirer
un prof de maths au secondaire il ya 47
ans et aucune déchets qui lui dans sa
tête je suis l'ami à son frère illias
pâte et leye poté telle
c'est un trip heures de vélo montant
khiter de moi lui dormait dans une
chambre d'un trop-plein collis de
solides relais pour paraître seul est
vraiment autres puits
et jusqu'à me choque le ça retombe rouge
il ya plein de charognards de moi chants
tabarnak à ce moment-là je me dis je te
jure la la la la prime est passé en
temps c'est oui je m'achète un billet
d'avion et jeu des coulisses j'ai pas
besoin
ma vie va bien qu'est-ce que je me fais
chier phoque tout ce jeu marque alice
j'en reviens maison puis je veux jouer
au bordel joie et de bonne humeur
si c'est ma vie antalis et au moment où
je me disais il ya un néo zélandais qui
fait inédit jamais et je t'aime je pense
que ma classe j'ai pété les ifs est ok
pour un debrief regarde il regarde à
travers ton nom pour vraiment me dit il
dit maintenant je parlais pas dessus je
parlais pas de la 20 apparitions divines
tant besoin de toi c'est ça ma clope à
la main sur les questions
une idée qui a fait de la toile comme
acquis way mais j'ai rien à y dire il y
avait une longue file de charade honneur
demain mieux gérer le trafic
toutes les sortes les gens il m'a aidé à
reculer fac trente deux secondes après
j'étais stationné y est comme le numéro
de téléphone pour appeler accompagner
jusqu'au mois avant le terme
initialement jeté comme qu'est ce qui
vient de se passer des mots dont je suis
il m'a tellement calme et il m'a
tellement fait de bien et les néo
zélandais c'est les gens les plus
gentils au monde livré le sont tellement
gentils c'est incroyable puis puis je me
suis calmé tout ça fait quand même pas
en danger je pense que je cherchais ici
mais je cherchais de quoi depuis juin
j'aimerais faire quelque chose puisque
correct mais ça a été facile sur la
réflexion et comme on going puis
mais c'est ben c'est vraiment spécial
qui se passe en ce moment ses jetons en
australie quand fait éclater les gens
chez qui un matin je le lave vaisselle
puis finalement le lendemain matin hier
et puis comme je me suis acheté un
billet d'avion pour trois ans plus tard
puis j'ai décollé j'en étais si vraiment
vous autres que je voulais faire avec
avec votre jeu parlant du ciblage avait
baissé les grilles même s'il pleut tous
les autres qu'elle était tout et quand
même depuis au débat lite tu t'es
impliqué des oies un titre c'est ça fait
comme partisan d un mot giraldi beaucoup
de choses
dans les derniers mois pis c'est que
c'est impossible pour moi
peut-être parce que je suis pas où a
lieu de cette façon-là d'avoir de me
diriger dans trop de directions
c'est vraiment vraiment difficile pour
moi de faire ce que ce soit de vouloir
et peut-être m'impliquer dans trop
d'affaires de vouloir porter ma voix
trop d'enfants puis parce que parce que
inévitablement se jeter par mon passé de
sport je sais que quand tu essaies de
faire trois affaires différentes
quand tu t'entraînes pour trois choses
ce vote entraîné mal pour trois choses
puisqu'elle s'entraîne pour une un
objectif précis ben si c'est
optimalement là que ça va bien
fonctionner ici puis puisse agir a
indiqué qu' il y avait trop d'affaires
dans ma tête que j'ai commencé à vouloir
mal à apprivoiser trop de problématiques
sociales me tombe puis fait que j'ai
décidé de faire ce que je veux juste me
reconcentrer sur qu'est-ce qu'une caisse
que moi je vais fort qu'est ce qui me
tient à coeur maintenant
puis le studio s'amener vraiment un bon
exemple si tu parlais de conversation
mais je trouve que tu sais moi je me
nourris de podcasts c'est là que je vais
chercher mon information quotidienne
c'est là que je recherchais medef mais
mes discussions de profondeur
quotidienne c'est la conversion
divertissement où puis je trouve que si
tout le monde était si mettons tout
point tel matin à l'école petit faisait
faire une caisse qui s'est passé dans le
monde aujourd'hui à tous les matins show
qu'on serait vraiment - ya eu en ce
moment en tant que société ça je trouve
que l'information c'est vraiment la clé
pi2 commun transmettre l'information de
la façon la plus effective et nuancée
possible pour que le monde puisse se
l'approprier fait que de vouloir mettre
plus mon énergie dans ce dans des
discussions
je pense que ça c'est quelque chose qui
me nourrit qui me donne envie de
m'impliquer qui me donne envie de
d'aller de l'avant dans cette direction
là c'est vraiment quelque chose qui qui
qui m'habite
puis c'est encore une fois je trouve que
je trouve qu'un clivage tellement grand
dans la société
une dichotomie tellement claire entre
deux parties
et puis on le voit on le voit vraiment
beaucoup en ce moment on le voit
beaucoup du tout digne on réalise qu'on
écoles issement chanceux finalement au
québec le titre we de la droite ou de la
gauche mais on s'entend que peu importe
le parti pour qui tu vas voter personnes
vont se retrouver dans mardi puis si
j'ai comme l'impression qu'il faut
trouver une façon de faire un pont parce
que le sait c'est toi tu es conservateur
tout est libéral je vous pourrez nous
autres les mecs et ses méthodes en son
centre
si tu donnes un libéral qui y a pas de
discussion possible
les discussions sont coupé les ponts le
pont qui traverse cette rivière là et
couper complètement puis il faut trouver
une façon que les gens puissent
traverser le pont parce que sinon ça
fait trop ça fait un fossé qui est trop
grand se trouvent six mois c'est la
chose qui m'habite présentement plus que
toutes les causes plus que le véganisme
plus que tout les choses c'est on pourra
pas aller de l'avant en tant que société
si on reste aussi divisés
catégoriquement
puis ça commence par l'homme le plus
puissant au monde et je reviens je
reviens somme ça commence par l'homme le
plus puissant au monde peut pas être un
diviseur aussi catégorie c'est
impossible c'est un précepteur l'on l'a
vu au québec en ce moment avec la crise
avec l'aco vite tout le monde s'est
rallié derrière le goya personnes à port
pour quelques petites affaires le team
ya personne qui comme fait à et le
gouvernement de la caq font une mauvaise
job c'est comme au quai non on embarque
dans ce pays malgré la situation du que
viennent je trouve qu'au québec on a été
plus unis que jamais dans les derniers
mois ceux-ci se trouvent sur le trop
positifs
mais à l'échelle planétaire que trop un
grand clivage pipi
moi je trouve que c'est le problème
c'est le plus grand problème qu'on vit
en ce moment c'est une trop grande
séparation entre les idéaux qui une trop
grande coupure dans la conversation fait
que je suis j'ai serge essai j'essaie de
réhabiliter ceux du mieux que je peux
avec des conversations comme ceux
abonnés des tribunes à tout le monde qui
veut s'exprimer longtemps de façon
intelligente et web dans un espace où il
ya du respect de l'écouté
by cc ses joggings l'antiquité comme ait
la meilleure manière d'avancer avec qui
tu es pas d'accord si ou hollande -
calmement
tu peux ne pas être d'accord avec
quelqu'un calmement ça suivait cpie de
monsieur remettons ça ça m'a aidé avant
une meilleure écoute
ouais bah oui écoutez plus pistes
importantes et avec avec le genre de
deux tribunes qu'on a mené c'est comment
mon dieu tu me suis pas là pour donner
de l'information ti cho poche je pense
je suis là pour divertir pu agacer du
quai d'une certes je sais pas le tgcc
même mois le jeu comme je sais pas je
m'apprête jeu manu je m'attribue pour ça
mais je veux peut-être plus que juste
divertir matin est ce que tu as
l'impression c'est le feeling que j'ai
dit je trouve que quand tu circule sur
les réseaux sociaux il y beaucoup de
futilité et puis moi j'en suis même
coupable c'est moi même je mets des
trucs des fois qu'ils sont pas
pertinents nécessairement technique puis
qu'ils aient juste parce que c'est ma
vie au quotidien mais mais je trouve que
beaucoup d'utilité est ce qu est ce que
tu sens que met on de prendre la
position ce soit par rapport aux
derniers événements au par rapport à
juste n'importe quelle position
politique ou sociale ou ideo est ce qu
est ce que tu crois que l'auteur a passé
l'étape puisqu'il s'est plus rendue
possible de dire oh non moi je moi je
moi je m'implique pas ouais c'est un
passé maintenant moi je pense que c'est
parce que c'est impossible de dire et
moi mettons moi je veux je sais
continuer à montrer du rêve ces réseaux
sociaux à faire juste prendre mes belles
photos mais je trouve que je trouve que
tu peux plus te cacher derrière le ça me
tente pas de m'impliquer parce que je
m'implique pas là je pense que
maintenant ce que tu dis en ce moment ça
me parle énormément c'est comme ce que
moi je me sens aussi été après si je
pense qu'il faut que ce soit en lien
avec ta personne
fall a fait moi mettons je suis rendu à
un point où ses jambes
j'ai un lien très différent des sur les
réseaux sociaux mettant avec les réseaux
sociaux que mes seins vous ma famille
parce que moi ça fait partie de mon
travail je range avec une tribune qu'il
faut pas trop je pense pas ce qu'attend
il ya du monde qui est marc sarreau
fameux levier comme patti tu fais jamais
de story où tu parle des fois ça m'a à
chaque fois que on voit que des mines
story mopi martin on est comme on attend
de voir si tu vas faire un job qui
choisit jamais comme un peu jamais pensé
à ses jeux comme on dirait que j je
pense tout le temps plus du côté négatif
j'ai toujours peur enfin si je mets ça y
est tous quelque chose de bon qui
pourrait sortir de tout cela dont il va
toujours avoir cessé alors que le gvt
est assez vrai il ya plein de styles
beaucoup de gens qui me suivent ils sont
beaucoup plus comme ma soeur que l'
inverse meilleur de moi pour moi que
encore une fois dans mon voyage j'ai
fait la première c'est mon dieu j'ai pas
été sur instagram du tout pendant une
semaine et puis ça m'était pas arrivé
depuis que j'ai un style presque parce
que ben c'est un outil travail et il ça
me fait ch et qui plaide enfin ça me
fait du bien ça me faisait comme ça
vraiment 6 est survenu avec un regard un
peu plus clair genre ok qu'est ce que
moi je veux faire là dessus qu'est ce
que comment
les gens que j'admire l'utilisent comme
un c j'écoutais un podcast que j'ai
adoré que j'écoutais en travaillant
chance et python be your man wild avec
bobonne m le numéro 3 est beau bonhomme
est sorti à l'automne l'humoriste est un
réalisateur exactement et cdf qui me
ferait découvrir et il réalise un film
écrit et scénarisé lui-même qui
s'appelle et grid
ah ouais ouais ce extraordinaire qui est
qui qui parle d'une jeune fille en suède
c'est tout son rapport aux réseaux
sociaux puis aux autres ce qu'ils mènent
dans cette conversation le il ya tout ce
qu'ils disent est comme je t'ai
l'enchantent je disais à voix haute
toute seule au fond de la terre
oui oui crise oui aussi sauter quand
j'ai réalisé plein d'affaires il était
exigeant
ils n'étaient pas critiques j'ai trouvé
il était exigeant envers le milieu de la
culture aux états unis que ce soit les
late night que ce soit le divertissement
que ce t il était exigeant très exigeant
avec eux tout son rapport aux réseaux
sociaux comme il voit les ficelles du
jeu mais comme tellement plus clairement
tout le monde puis ça comme fait ça me
fait du bien d'entendre ce ça fait
comment ma réflexion par rapport à ça le
grandit qui fait en sorte que
dernièrement j'ai eu un espèce de
sentiment où j'étais quand même pas
capable de juste faire du divertissement
après si je pense que c'est peut-être dû
au fait que j'ai pas de show c'est quand
audrey quand j'ai des shows j'ai comme
cet exutoire là où je peux faire des jo
qui sont importantes pour moi ok mais
qui sont pas nécessairement sociale puis
c'est correct mais je sais pas les
réseaux sociaux pour un mot cette
semaine ce qui est arrivé c'est que
j'ai vu et l'aura de milk and bones
faire un pause qui disait si vous avez
une tribune puis vous réagissez pas à ce
qui se passe en ce moment avec black
light bearer vous êtes dans le torse et
puis ça moche et qui j'ai fait fort
qu'il faut que je fasse quelque chose à
part à moi en ce moment et puis je me
suis assis avec un papier crayon puis
j'ai juste fait comment je me sens
comment je me sens par rapport à ce
qu'est ce qui se passe parce que ça
faisait c'était relativement récent le
savez puis gervais puis à papier crayon
j'ai écrit comment je me sentais jusqu'à
temps que j'ai plus rien à dire puis
littéralement c'est ce que j'ai posté
j'ai fait je l' ai relu j'ai fait ça
fait du sens pour moi ça disent que je
suis capable de dire en ce moment - avec
l'information avec l'information j'écris
les connaissances que j'ai si tout ce
que je capable de dire je vais le dire
puis et j'ai mis une photo de franco
chine parce que je la d'empiler
représenté sur piles puis je t'ai puis
après si j'avais quelque chose à faire
enfin que j'ai pas touché qui met
réseaux sociaux avec la télécommande
exact je cite certains j'y retourne chez
qui je peux dire allez les commentaires
mais le jeu c'est turquie a rien négatif
que ça fait de boer 17 ans puis matthew
goss était même poste jeter comme je
veux j'ai pas je suis pas le gars et je
suis très nuancée dans vie je suis bien
dans la zone grise
mamani faut peut-être des opinions
batteux pas le choix d'en prendre
puis j'en ai pas tant que ça c'est ce
que j'ai réalisé faire en fait peut-être
que ce pacte en a pas tant que pendant
des opinions c'est sur le trouve que
peut-être qu'ils sont pas arrêtés parce
que tu t'es peut-être pas poser
longuement la question pour quelle est
mon opinion way est important de
l'opinion 6 est en constante évolution
ce une réflexion si c'est ici le podcast
si on attendait d'avoir une opinion
arrêté sur quelque chose maintenant pas
et on dirait rien je pense que j'ai
comme fait la paix avec l'idée de dire
quelque chose que je vais regretter plus
tard je me savais partie de la victime
et ont su écouter les podcasts que j'ai
faites vous là je m'écoutais je dis et
button opinion là-dessus était point
fort mais pas bien bien d'avancer pas
bien réfléchi mais c'est pas grave ça
sert je pense que le monde qui nous
écoutent aussi ils sont dans cette
constante évolution de ce constant de
réflexion le tai chi aujourd'hui on
parle de choses bip plus comme si la
pression dont tu parlais team et au de
laurence betti de dire de la réponse
parce qu'on a la responsabilité de
réfléchir à ça il faut réfléchir ces
enjeux là tout le monde
t mais il ya aussi un temps avant de
parler fort et j'ai fac ci donne pas
l'impression d'avoir assez réfléchi pour
parler peut-être mieux continue
d'écouter parce que de repartager
quelque chose ou qu'elle te pas vraiment
réfléchi parce que en bout de ligne les
actions place par le look et les mots
aussi puis les réseaux sociaux c'est pau
c'est pour la brévine à 100 pour ça non
plus
c'était important de poster ce important
de diffuser le message mais c'est
important de vives partie de pensée et
d'action précis par exemple absolument
bien aussi c'est que de ce temps le sait
tellement rendu gros les réseaux sociaux
que je trouve que le québec est rendu
très petit là dessus on voudrait que
tout le monde pour le meilleur et pour
le pire
si je regardais le sait le lay le
dernier live d'arnaud solide s'est jetée
comme j'avais l'impression de vivre
quelque chose avec tout le québec on est
là pour l'été chez pol en douze équipes
gagnent quand sa pop jeudi un live quand
ça papa 12 et 15 mille tu peux être sûr
que lotus en mille personnes uniques qui
ont passé sur six mondes en tab actifs
ou le tipi jeter leurs pis je t'ai comme
assez spécial s'y passe en ce moment tu
sais justice téléphone mais moi je sais
que ça vient les réseaux sociaux mais
c'est que ça devient trop tout la même
affaire c'est que ce qui est cool tout
le monde dit que c'est cool ce qui est
out tout le monde il ya plus d'une liste
et il ya plus de
comme annoncé comme un jeu réd comme se
dit d'un petit jeu ben je veux choisir
les moments joyeux
puis j'ai commencé à une folle ou et
plein de monde puis c'est pour moi c'est
même rien quant aux autres ce que tu
vois c'est un autre à faire que jeu
comme à magog
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'ils vont
penser de moi la dame comme si ma soeur
était pas ma soeur je la suivrai pas ces
réseaux sociaux la collation qui a fait
pour son gars ça m'intéresse parce que
sont gaussés mon filleul
sinon je m'incruste et fac est que
toutes les mères c'est pas dire que
c'est pas dire que c'est pas important
pour quelqu'un c'est ça fait que ma
réflexion par rapport aux réseaux
sociaux est vraiment vraiment en guang
est ce que j'aime autant du podcast
c'est que les podcasts que j'écoutais
dernièrement aussi c'est que les prêts
les personnes prennent le temps on a le
temps d'expliquer d'être nuancée de 10
je pensais mais voici pourquoi où je
suis pas certain je pense que les gens
qui écoutent les podcasts sont comme
nous autres parce qu'on est sur nice
monde le typha que si je peux si vous
avez écouté de podcasts de marine
il ya deux trois semaines avec lynn
shelton qui est sa femme sa copine
depuis août donne est une réalisatrice
productrice elle est à le travailler sur
des projets super cool vraiment une
femme allumé sur parlophone py qui
semblait grandes marques très heureux le
team mclaren qui est assez brumeux la
com com monsieur est décédé subitement
du jour au lendemain
pas de l'aco vide ne sais pas quoi et
décider le samedi et le lundi c'est lui
quand il reçut lui il a rencontré sur
son pack casse en 2015
quand quelqu'un décède qui a déjà reçu
il repose la conversation qu'il a eue
avec la personne et le lundi
il repose sa conversation avec de 2015
mais avec sa blonde puis il fait l'intro
deux jours après cette tragédie le match
des jeux ramasser des branches sur mon
terrain puis place et elle met ses
voisins mais je te regarder dans ce gala
qui fait des fois de sonorama ramassant
des branches oussékine nouveau vélo
mais j'étais j'avais rarement eu accès à
quelque chose d'aussi réel docile vrai
d'ossip urd aussi sincère d'aussi
vulnérable même lui lisait il était
comme je sais pas si je suppose est en
train de faire ce que je tenterai ferme
est à toi radu fois que je le fais puis
mme estelle charge et émotivement le
puits après cela conversation skiff
octobre ce qu'est une seconde après dans
nos oreilles est vivante et le même qui
reste cinq ans à vivre fax et comme il
ya quelque chose de très humain là
dedans je trouve qu'il ya des fois sur
les réseaux sociaux c'est l'authenticité
sommes plus parodique et qu'elle
entendait discuter c'est qu' aucun moyen
de savoir si la cause que tu défends
hausse la chose que tu reportage c'est
vraiment tu es vrai valeur dans ce sens
qu'il ya quelque chose qui vient du
coeur qui réfléchit petite porte pic du
temps par la clé gendre de toit ou si
comme abc la chaîne et aucun moyen de
savoir ce que je sais c'est de passer si
knicks étaient optimistes ce déballage
et mieux faire confiance aux membres de
de prendre 3 qui savait la bonne place
montraient qu'il était temps de six mois
mois justement depuis depuis les
événements depuis georges fleuve depuis
tout ce qui a suivi j'ai je suis muet
complètement sur les réseaux sociaux
parce que je réfléchisse très vite
apprendre et réfléchir c'est notre place
à dante vous parlez en autour de ta moan
et 3 blancs
amman et sait se tait à ce qu'est mon
rôle c'est de parler ce que mon rôle est
d'écouter ce que demont al sid
c'est très complexe car absolument
justement on en parle avant mai à
bayonne fait une fête une vidéo s qui
parlait je te demande de cette espèce de
pression là-dessus white duke une des
affaires qui a dit dans cette courte
vidéo de trois minutes qui était et moi
qui m'occupe flash et si tu vas jamais
goûté fait que tu veux tu veux jamais
rendre quelqu'un sympathique attaquant
soit tu vas jamais réussir à faire
changer les ice man quelqu'un en
pointant du doigt puis en disant qu est
coupable c'est pas il va agir sur la
sous la culpabilité mais c'est pas ça
qui va faire réfléchir qui va y faire
penser à ce fait qu'il y à un essai du
site cette distinction là et on va
terminer la première partie de la
conversation qui règne sur ce
cliffhanger
on va transférer la partie 2 sur 10 du
temps discute
si vous avez aimé ce qu'il entendait
transférer sur l'autre chaîne puis on
continue cette conversation mi en
discute
ouais